He tried guilt tripping me into having
sex by sending me photos of him fake
crying and implying that I owe him
sex for all that he does for me.
Guilt tripping for sex is like a really
threatening thing. You know? It's,
it's your body.
It's your choice.
Okay.
My name is Jennifer. I'm a mother.
I'm a pastor and I'm an author.
My name is Daniela and diamond Muslim,
Syrian American spoken word artists.
My name is in their brief core. I'm in
Punjabi sick woman. I'm an activist,
a writer and a sister.
My girlfriend's need for me to catalog
her life for Instagram constantly is
slowly draining my soul.
I feel you.
I enjoy taking pictures
just as much as anyone else,
but when I have to take 400 plus photos,
yes, you read that number, right?
It becomes difficult to help cope.
I've thought of taking caffeine. Oh,
Adderall weed or just running
into oncoming traffic. Oh my God.
Anyone have any healthier
alternatives as some of his, Scott,
will this love hate relationship with
social media? I feel you because it's,
it becomes such a suffocating experience.
There's always that question of like,
why am I taking this photo or video?
Exactly.
Maybe this is totally wrong assessment,
but I feeling of like I want it to be
perfect, I want it to look perfect,
I want it to be, you know. Right.
And there's probably some deeper stuff
in there that needs to be healed and
dealt with and my advice would be
put healthy boundaries and just say,
here's the deal. Hey, we're going to
spend 15 minutes, 20 minutes, whatever.
Set your boundary of like getting
you your picture that you want.
But after that we're not going to,
we're going to actually put our phones
away and just engage and enjoy each other.
That's what I need. Right. So you get what
you need but I need to get what I need.
Yeah. Maybe he can be the one
to kind of address like what's,
what is the cause behind this
need for the increased photos?
My boyfriend and I are both virgins here
recently started begging for sex and
when I wouldn't give in,
he tried guilt tripping me into having
sex by sending me photos of him fake
crying and implying that I owe him
sex for all that he does for me.
He later apologized for acting
that way. How do I seed? For me,
if I was in that situation,
I'd, I'd be like, okay,
I really need you to honor this
boundary, right. Honor this thing.
And if you can't,
like I don't have to put a little bit
of distance because that would make me a
little bit concerned of if he,
if he's not willing to honor this area,
that's important to me. It's going
to be hard to trust in other areas.
As a survivor of domestic violence,
I can relate to a certain extent because
emotional manipulation is a big part
that often goes unseen. Yeah. Um,
and so she mentioned guilt tripping.
That is an emotional abuse
even though he apologize.
I would suggest kind of
maybe checking patterns.
Has this happened before and
in other areas, like you said,
it breaks trust and if that it just
escalates into something worse and guilt
tripping for a sex is like a really
threatening thing. You know, it's,
it's your body, it's your choice. When
should you have sex for the first time?
I've realized that you need to be
absolutely comfortable with the person.
You need to make sure that
they will respect you.
You need to make sure that they know
who you are, what your boundaries are.
Absolutely.
I think sometimes one side,
often over romanticizes how committed
they are to that relationship and you
think you're ready,
but you have to dig deep and to know
what you're feeling and and just an
understanding that
you're on the same page.
When my husband I chose to do was to
not fully give ourselves until we were
fully committed to each
other and got married.
I'm grateful that we chose that path
because in their safety in that knowing
that you're giving yourself to somebody
who's going to forever be with you and
be by your side.
My fiance is leaving me for another
woman whom he has had an emotional affair
with for a month.
I don't know how I can ever trust a man
again or even find someone with the same
priorities as me. I'm so devastated
and don't know what to do with myself.
That's really hard. That's
heavy. You like process that
when we're in pain and grief we don't
always think clearly or make good
decisions, you know? So
being mindful of that,
don't make any rash decisions
in that time and that place. Um,
there are good people out there.
I was in my early twenties when
this actually happened and you know,
like all pain, all
breakups. This one was very,
very painful and my personality
very much is, you know,
if something huge happens to me, something
devastating happens, I will collapse.
And so don't put yourself through
that, talk about it, write about it.
If that's what helps you,
it just let it out of your system.
Like my friends have said, I know
it's hard. I've been through as well.
I've been through a divorce and
there are days where I'm like,
I don't know if I want to trust, but then
I'll meet people and I'm like, no, I,
I can trust.
And I build it gradually.
Time gives you experiences that rebuilds
you to where you need to be later on.
And that's how it heals
you. So, yeah. So true.
My body has changed for the worst after
a major accident and I can't bring
myself to be intimate with my boyfriend
because I'm scared he'll be repulsed by
how I look.
Is it better to break off the relationship
since I can't give him what he wants?
It didn't want to say you're a Rockstar
for surviving this, you know, um,
I can't even imagine what you've been
through, but just remember that, you know,
you have not changed. I'm
sure your partner is still
thinks that way. Yeah. Yeah.
And probably all of us have
had at some point in our life,
like really painful things
that have happened that have
made us who we are today,
even though it's been a point
of great pain in her life.
Learning to see it as it's making me
who I am today, it's made me stronger.
It's made me better. Right? I
think it's for a lot of women,
it's like a lifetime journey that we
experienced. It's roller coasters.
When I was 11, um, I was
diagnosed with OCD and um,
something called Trichotillomania,
which is like a compulsive behavior of
hair plucking. And so ever since I was 10,
11,
I had to wear eyeliner and eye brow pencil
and I've literally never said this to
anyone.
So you are like,
as a kid I just liked registered that
like I'm ugly, I'm going to cry right now.
So I have had to wear makeup my whole
life and I've always felt like I can't
make eye contact with anyone.
I can't be seen and um,
went through a lot and I
like managed to control it.
It still happens every once in a while.
But I always thought that if
I ever enter a relationship,
he would find that really ugly and leave.
And then on top of that,
being a Muslim woman that wears the
head cover, I'm facing a lot of, um,
ironically it's not discrimination
from the outside world,
but it's like my own Muslim
communities. Like, you know,
a lot of men don't want a woman
that wears the head cover.
And so I've had opportunities where I've
been rejected for choosing to practice
my faith by my own people.
And so I can totally relate
to that because it just, it's,
it's really unfair the pressures that
they put on a women's expectations.
It's like you're not even seeing who I am.
It's just been this ongoing journey
of, no, I love who I am as a person,
but I don't know if I
love what I look like.
This is such a good example of
even our own perceptions, right?
Because all I've been doing is staring
at how gorgeous you are. Right?
So from my perspective,
I'm sitting here and I just think you're
so beautiful and yet you struggle with
that. All of us can relate to that.
Right? And so thank you for sharing that.
My advice would be be honest.
If this is your intimate partner
who's chosen you for you,
they should have absolutely no problem
being there and supporting you and loving
you regardless of any physical or
even emotional changes that happen.
That's a relationship. Right? You know,
sometimes we do forget that it's important
to uplift one another and we forget
that, you know, other
folks have troubles too.
And it's important to
help them and advise them.
We have way more in common than we have
in differences and these were amazing
women to sit with today and just talk
to real life stuff that so many of us
women face.
I ended up revealing a lot about myself
that I'm not usually comfortable sharing,
but um, it felt like a safe space and
it just reminds me that we're all human,
so we end up experiencing the
same things at the end of the day.
And so it was just a unifying experience.
What's up guys? This is
Ian, and this is John.
We work at jubilee and we're always
making things to empower people to live to
their fullest potential.
Trying to make some meaningful things in
the internet world where there's a lot
of noise.
Check out some of our other videos right
here and let us know what you think in
the comments below this video and also
be sure to click subscribe over here.
Yeah,
let's live greater together and onward
and upward all the time and we'll see you
guys around.